you've got a calculator that will handle
ten digits or more you may bring it out
I'm going to try to square a five digit
number five digit number but to make my
job more interesting for you as well as
for me I'm going to I'm going to do this
last problem thinking out loud so you
can actually honestly hear what's going
on in my mind while I do a calculation
of this size now let's create a five
digit number I'll go up this aisle here
if I can get the first five of you to
call out a single digit that will be the
five digit number that I'll square go
ahead
eight two six nine haha 78 thousand two
hundred sixty nine squared yuck might
even be Prime I don't know let me show
you how I'm going to attempt this
problem I'm going to break the problem
down into three parts I'll do 78,000
squared plus 269 squared plus 78
thousand times 269 times to add all
those numbers together and with any luck
arrive at the answer now let me recap
thank you while I explain something else
as I do this last calculation you might
hear certain words as opposed to numbers
creep into the calculation let me
explain what that is this is a phonetic
code a mnemonic device that I use that
allows me to convert numbers into words
I store them as words and later on
retrieve them as numbers I know it
sounds complicated it's not I just don't
want you to think you're seeing
something out of Rain Man here
there's definitely a method to my
madness definitely definitely sorry one
last instruction for my judges with
calculators now you should have a ten
digit answer probably begins with a six
and ends with a one in between I don't
know there is at least a 50% chance that
I'll make a mistake somewhere in the
middle if I do don't tell me what the
mistake is just say your clothes or
something and I'll try and figure it out
which can be pretty entertaining in
itself if however I am right whatever
you do don't keep it to yourselves
all right make sure everybody knows that
I got the answer right because this is
my Big Finish
if you have an answer in front of you
raise your hand just so I see we're okay
a bunch of you out there great um I'll
even tell you one more detail that I
normally normally don't reveal I'll tell
you how I'm gonna do 78 times to 69 to
69 is prime but it's one less than 270
which is very composite I'll take
advantage of that okay so without any
more stalling here we go I'll start the
problem in the middle with 78 times to
69 I let's to it 270 is 27 is 9 times 3
78 times 9 is 700 2 times 3 is 21 Oh 6
as 20 1060 20 1060 minus 78 is 20,000
compliment 982 20,000 982 double that to
get 41,000 864 41,000 864 becomes right
Fisher right Fisher is 41,000 864 that
seems that seems wrong actually I'm
going to try that one again
so I get one more time I get 20 106
that's 20 172 2106 20 1060 20 1060
subtract the 78 I'm getting 20,000 982
double that to get 4d I'm worried about
this here 40 oh I got it 41,000 964
there we go 41,000 964 becomes right
pitcher right pitcher I think that works
40 oh right pitcher okay next I do 78
squared which is 6,000 84 so I can say
six billion take the 84 add that too
right 84 plus 41 is 125 but I see a
carry so it's 126 million pitcher
pitcher know yet not yet pitcher pitcher
next I do 269 squared that's 300 times
238 plus 31 squared seventy one thousand
four hundred plus nine sixty one seventy
two thousand three sixty one machete if
I need it machete take the 72 add that
to pitcher to get thirty six thousand
three hundred sixty one yes good thank
you very much I hope you enjoyed
mathemagics thank you
you